và hẳng tin tân hòa sã đưa tin, bở lượng kéo sài dùng ngày qua đã gây ra lũ lũ lũ lũ nếu chiểm trọng tại mình trong và tây năm nước này,
khiến nhất 2 người thiệt mạng và khoảng 2 mình người vẫn mất tích.
Nếu lũ sân nhanh, bụt các lực lượng cứ hộ về chiểm khai chiếc dịch tìm kiếm cơ ngạn quý mọi lượng tại nhiều địa phương,
tại tình quý châu, nhiều khu dân cư và giữ tế cánh các bị nghiệp sâu, người thiệt hại nặn nè trên sản xuân nguyệp.
Ở thi chắn chừng mình được lượng kông hộ đã sài cụi tình gông 2 người cầu tuổi,
để mất kẻ trưng nhà sau khi tình chìm biến lượng những chiểm,
tại tình hồ bắt, mơ lượng khiến lượng nước sống dân câu,
người nghiệp mùi cuo dân cư và chiếc các sợ thông tạng dụt khu cửc.
Được lượng kông hộ phải dí chuyển như dơ của địa hình nghiệp sâu để tiếp cạnh và sự tán hư dân.
Chỉnh quyền địa phương sân nhận tàn bộ dân tại các khu vực điện lượng,
đã được sơ tán ăn thoàn.
Bộ tạng nguyên nước Trung Quốc đã tiếp gọi cơ trở phó hình cấp,
cấp bộn tại mấy tình yêu cầu tăng cường tình mà ốc và chiến khai địa phóng trong lượng lượng,
nhằm dạm thử thứ thải, chứ mất cạnh thử tiếp cơ góan thứ hộn bịn vức tạng.